[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec à mes
côtés kathia gilder onge enquêteurs
bonjour oriane est avec nous cette
semaine une rancune grand son bonjour
bonjour député la république en marche
de paris et vous êtes vice-président de
l'assemblée nationale on va commenter la
semaine avec vous avec d'abord
l'adoption du projet de loi à
l'assemblée qui instaure un droit à
l'erreur il a été voté à une large
majorité
mais sans unanimité le gouvernement en
face au mouvement de colère des
personnels des ehpad les établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes dépendantes
colère relayé à l'assemblée on le verra
nicole belloubet est auditionné au sénat
la ministre de la justice longuement
interrogé sur le mouvement des
surveillants de prison et puis on
parlera de la révision constitutionnelle
sur les rails mais les désaccords sont
encore nombreux entre l'assemblée et le
sénat avec à l'horizon l'option du
référendum et on va tout de suite
commencé la semaine en invoquant sa
bonne foi il sera désormais possible
d'éviter les sanctions de
l'administration le droit à l'erreur a
été adoptée à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le projet doit été largement voté en
première lecture 405 voix pour quarante
et une contre les républicains se sont
abstenus les insoumis et les communistes
ont voté contre
compte rendu de séance avec céline
martel pour 405 contre 41
une très large majorité pour le projet
de loi confiance avec ce texte le
gouvernement veut établir en droit à
l'erreur pour les usagers des
administrations
en clair en droit de se tromper dans
leur déclaration sans risquer une
sanction dès le premier manquement
enfin enfin avec ce texte nous osons
renverser la logique passer d'une
société et d'une administration qui
fonctionne et qui contrôle à une
administration qui conseille une
administration qui s'engage une
administration qui dialoguent les
services des impôts devraient se montrer
plus clément en cas d'oubli
si un contribuable se signale lui même
les intérêts de retard seront divisées
de moitié les entreprises pourront
désormais demander une administration de
les contrôler pour s'assurer de leur
conformité
seuls les communistes et la france ont
soumis sont voté contre
en utilisant l'expression séductrice du
droit à l'erreur vous ne semblez vous
êtes préoccupé que d'une seule chose
lâchait encore un peu plus de lest pour
les entreprises au nom de la
compétitivité et de la réduction des
coûts on ne rétablit pas la confiance en
refusant d'obliger les entreprises comme
lactalis a publié ses comptes
on ne rétablit pas la confiance en
limitant la présence des services de
contrôles dans les entreprises on
rétablit pas non plus la confiance quand
on bafoue le code du travail en
désarmant les inspecteurs du travail
les républicains se sont abstenus il
juge que le texte ne va pas assez loin
pourquoi ne pas avoir souhaité ouvrir un
vrai débat préalable sur le périmètre du
texte est aussi sur ses ambitions
plutôt que de le réduire inexorablement
un catalogue de quelques mesures 5e les
unes avec les autres et qui en exclut
d'autres qui elles sont attendus par nos
concitoyennes les quarante trois
articles du projet de loi confiance
devront maintenant être débattu au sénat
alors une rançon ce texte a été voté
avec une large majorité pourtant y'a pas
eu d'unanimité parce que certains
estiment qu'il ne va pas assez loin
notamment il ya eu un amendement pour
obliger lactalis à rendre ses comptes
publics en tout cas certains grands
groupes comme lactalis est ce que on
aurait pu aller plus loin déjà rares
sont les textes qui font l'objet d'une
unanimité
ce qui est important de dire aujourd'hui
je crois c'est que c'était au coeur du
projet présidentiel d'emmanuel macron
que de dire qu'il était essentiel de
simplifier et de changer les relations
entre l'administration et les citoyens
ce texte il a deux objets c'est à la
fois faire confiance et faire simple
c'est simplifier les démarches mais
c'est allé au-delà de ce qu'ils avaient
donc mission accomplie pour les faire
confiance c'est considérer qu'en effet
l'administration n'est pas là que pour
sanctionner pour contrôler pour venir à
postériori dire aux citoyens qu'il a
bien fait ou mal fait elle peut être
saisi l'administration par le citoyen en
amont pour dialoguer pour concerter pour
orienter et c'est ce nouveau rapport
entre les français et leur
administration qu on essaye de mettre en
place
aujourd'hui c'est au coeur de notre
projet c'est un projet de simplification
et il s'agit en réalité de faciliter la
vie de chacun de faciliter les parcours
c'est de créer des référents uniques
donc c'est je crois une grande avancée
dans l'organisation administrative de ce
pays et je regrette qu'il n'ait pas eu
d'unanimité mais je n'en suis pas
complètement surpris et vous ne craignez
pas que les sénateurs réécrivent le
texte et nos gars des sénateurs auront
certainement beaucoup à dire et beaucoup
à faire
évidemment mais c'est le principe de la
navette c'est un enrichissement mutuel
le texte reviendra à l'assemblée
nationale mais sur ce point comme sur
tous les autres nous serons évidemment
déterminé à mettre en place que nous
avons indiqué aux français pendant la
campagne toile nous avons mandat pour
réaliser ce type de réforme en
profondeur et nous les mènerons un autre
texte a suscité le débat à l'assemblée
une proposition de loi pour faire
reconnaître les pathologies résultant du
burn out l'état d'épuisement
professionnel un texte porté par
françois ruffin sur un ordre du jour
réservé au groupe de la france insoumise
texte rejeté en commission et en séance
publique
et pourtant oriane le sujet sera repris
par votre collègue de la république en
marche charlotte france
le coq qui s'est vu confier une mission
sur ce sujet on a l'impression que
françois ruffin s'est fait un peu voler
son nom jours et je pense qu'il faut il
faut sortir de ce type d' amalgame ou
d'interprétation le burn out c'est un
sujet extrêmement grave qui touche des
milliers de français aujourd'hui c'est
un syndrome le syndrome de l'épuisement
au travail de ses conséquences notamment
physique psychique mental qui a expliqué
le roman phrase rituelle s'en expliquer
à l'évidence la france insoumise a
souhaité se saisir de ce sujet mais a
souhaité s'en saisir de manière un peu
caricaturale vous n'avez évidemment vous
avez été là pour vérifier que la
proposition de loi était techniquement
assez approximative juridiquement faible
qu'elle ne tenait pas la route
ce sujet a été saisie par le
gouvernement et par la majorité il ya
déjà plusieurs mois
il y à vous en avez parlé une mission
qui est conduite par charlotte lecoq qui
est bien plus large que celle du bernet
la scène c'est la santé au travail c'est
des pathologies au travail je crois
voilà que le sujet est assez grave pour
que nous ne tombions pas dans la
polémique politicienne
la france est soumise à essayer de faire
un coup à l'occasion d'une niche
parlementaire c'est bien normal et elle
est dans son rôle
je crois qu'aujourd'hui voilà c'est un
sujet grave c'est un sujet sur lequel il
faut qu'on réfléchisse il ya aujourd'hui
déjà 600 cas à peu près par an de burn
out qui sont reconnues comme maladies
professionnelles nous allons devoir
légiférer mais faisons le dans la
concertation dans le dialogue
la proposition françois ruffin n'a fait
l'objet d'aucune concertation d'aucun
dialogue
il l'a écrite dans son coin elle était
je voulais vous le dis et je vous le
répète techniquement faible et
juridiquement pas tenable et nous
souhaitons avancer et je ne doute pas du
coup que sur un processus qui aura été
le fruit d'une large concertation la
france insoumise pourra voter les textes
et les dispositions que nous mettrons en
place
autre sujet et grands sont le
gouvernement face à la colère des
personnels des maisons de retraite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une mobilisation inédite les
personnels soignants des ehpad les
maisons de retraite demande plus de
moyens pour faire correctement leur
travail
une grogne largement relayée dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
stéphanie des pierres partout dans
l'hémicycle les députés relais la colère
dans les ehpad sur les bancs de la
gauche fait simplement un jeu sorti un
match rc à droite aussi la france des
maisons de retraite et des hôpitaux de
proximité est une france qui souffre et
même au centre sur les bancs du modem
pourtant alliés de la majorité
ce n'est pas un cri de colère que je
pousse aujourd'hui c'est un cri d'alarmé
agnès buzyn la ministre de la santé se
retrouve sous les tirs croisés des
députés les parlementaires dénoncent les
conditions de vie et de travail dans les
maisons de retraite
vous vous rendez-compte madame la
ministre là où un personnel soignant
aimerait accompagner un ancien à la
salle à manger en lui tenant le bras
c'est que lui permettrait de garder un
peu plus de mobilité et bien en france
notre système incite à mettre cet ancien
dans un fauteuil roulant et perdre ainsi
en autonomie face au feu des critiques
la ministre qui a débloqué 50 millions
d'euros vendredi défend sa politique
elle rien que pour l'année 2018 près de
160 millions d'euros en plus ont été
alloués aux ehpad et des actions ciblées
seront menées pour accompagner les épate
les plus en difficulté le parti
socialiste n'est pas vraiment convaincu
votre gouvernement a offert 4 milliards
aux hommes % les plus riches avec 4
milliards on peut créer cent mille
postes de fonctionnaires intervenant
auprès des personnes âgées
agnès buzyn annonce aussi la nomination
d'un médiateur il devra veiller à la
bonne mise en oeuvre du plan de la
ministre une rançon d'un montant d'un
airbus a annoncé 50 millions
supplémentaires pour les agences
régionales de santé en plus des 100
millions déjà inscrits au budget 2008 de
la sécurité sociale est-ce que c'est
suffisant le gouvernement at il
suffisamment pris la mesure de cette
situation des fours budgétaire important
la v10 à peu près 160 millions au total
110 plus les 50 millions qui ont été
annoncées cette semaine bien avoir en
tête que le sujet des ehpad c'est plus
largement le sujet du vieillissement de
la population et du mercy la durée de
vie s'allonge et nous avons à faire une
place à nos aînés c'est une question de
société essentielle quelle place la
société va réserver à ses aînés c'est
une question de dignité humaine mais
c'est aussi une question de structure de
moyens d'accompagnement les ehpad sont
dans une situation évidemment difficile
et le gouvernement n'a pas attendu les
questions d'actualité de cette semaine
pour agir puisque il en a fait une
priorité depuis le mois de septembre
dernier
il y à des mesures qui ont été
détaillées par la ministre et que vous
venez de rappeler mais il va falloir au
delà du court terme dégager des moyens
investir détecter les ehpad qui sont le
plus en difficulté notamment suite à la
réforme de la tarification de 2016
ça c'est le court terme et puis sur le
long terme il faut qu'on s'interroge
réellement sur les moyens qu'on va
donner aux établissements les moyens
qu'on va donner à chacun des français
pour faire face justement à ces défis
nés était d'avoir un aîné qui parce que
les pathologies liées au vieillissement
de la population se développe
alzheimer parkinson et tout un tas de
pathologies neurodégénératives
comment est ce qu'on va essayer de
traiter ce problème vaste chantier mais
dans les médias ce que vous pensez que
le système de soins français ne va pas
pâtir tout de même du vaste plan
d'économies qui a annoncé dans la
fonction publique
on pense notamment la fonction publique
hospitalière qui risquerait d'en faire
les venant je ne crois pas et je pense
qu'il faut pas d'ailleurs mélanger les
sujets le sujet des ehpad et du
vieillissement de la population et du
financement du modèle parce que c'est de
ça dont il s'agit c'est un sujet
particulier spécifique sur lequel il
faut qu'on s'interroge le périmètre de
la fonction publique si vous évoquez ce
matin les les réformes qui ont été
annoncées hier par le le premier
ministre et par gérald darmanin
c'est un programme d'actions pour
repenser le périmètre de la sphère
publique pour savoir quelles sont les
missions utiles
quelles sont celles qui ne sont pas
utiles et pour accompagner les
fonctionnaires dans leur parcours
professionnel pour mieux valoriser leur
engagement leur mérite
et puis pour qui aura un impact sur la
fonction publique hospitalière
évidemment mais sa prise que sur les
autres mais c'est une c'est une autre
réflexion que nous
à voir et à l'évidence dans ce domaine
tout le monde sait que l'investissement
public le secteur public à un engagement
des si vous cessez 46% je crois de
mémoire à peu près 45 % des
établissements des ehpad qui sont un
public voilà il faut il faut qu'on est
con sorte là aussi d'aider des patients
et qu'on ait une vraie réflexion sur la
place que nous allons réserver à nos
aînés dans la france de 2010 8 19 heures
autre conflit celui des prisons la garde
des sceaux était auditionné devant le
sénat cette semaine la multiplication
des agressions en prison a déclenché la
colère du personnel pénitentiaire le
conflit est désormais apaisée mais la
crise n'est pas pour autant réglé
nicole belloubet la garde des sceaux
était auditionné jeudi au sénat et l
incite à développer les peines
alternatives à la prison l'écoutent
il faut donc donner aux magistrats les
moyens en toute sécurité de prononcer
des peines autre que de l'emprisonnement
cela veut dire par exemple que si le
magistrat souhaite prononcé un placement
sous bracelet électronique
il faut que ce placement là soient
sécurisés en termes de suivi de la
personne en termes de d'outillage bien
sûr mais il y a donc des conditions à
are vérifier il faut par ailleurs que
cette peine là deviennent une peine
autonome et ne soit plus une peine
d'aménagement de la peine de prison
comme c'est le cas actuellement grançon
pourquoi ces peines alternatives à la
prison ne sont pas plus souvent
impliqués à ce qu'il faut repenser la
politique pénale
chose qu'il faut repenser la politique
pénale vous avez raison et or en réalité
le mouvement auquel on a assisté là
c'est un mouvement qui a lui qui est né
d'agression scandaleuse dans milieu
carcéral et et qui posait la question de
la sécurité des agents de
l'administration pénitentiaire
évidemment mais au delà il faut avoir
une vraie réflexion sur le monde
carcéral sur le milieu carcéral
à quoi sert la prison je pense que
évidemment nous devons réfléchir et
c'est l'objet de l'accord qui a été
trouvé par le gouvernement avec eux le
syndicat majoritaire
il faut réfléchir aux conditions de
travail de ceux qui viennent exercer
leur mission professionnelle en milieu
carcéral bien sûr leur sécurité c'est
indispensable la valorisation de leur
engagement c'est indispensable
il ya d'autres réflexions à voir
efficacité de la politique pénale aussi
bien sûr quelles sont les peines les
plus adaptées parce qu'en réalité on
peut inventer
ici au parlement tout un tas de
dispositifs si les peines ne sont pas
appliqués aussi en réalité la politique
pénale n'est qu'une incantation
elle ne sera jamais efficace donc là il
faut vraiment réfléchir là dessus il
fait évidemment confiance à au
gouvernement et à nicole belloubet dont
je salue l'engagement pour pour mener ce
chantier
et puis il ya une réflexion qu'elle l'a
très bien géré et justement je pense
qu'on est on est sorti de la logique où
les ministres allaient immédiatement sur
le terrain faire des effets d'annoncé
pour essayer de traiter médiatiquement
un problème
elle a négocié un accord cet accord a
été acceptée par le syndicat majoritaire
le troisième point que je voulais
évoquer devant vous c'est qu'il faut
aussi réfléchir à ce qu'est la prison
aujourd'hui
et quelle est la finalité de
l'incarcération parce qu'en réalité
l'incarcération
c'est le mode le plus abouti dans la
sanction pénale
mais précisément elle vient sanctionner
une faute ne vient pas sanctionné une
existence et il faut s'interroger aussi
aux conditions de détention et donc
c'est la question des programmes
immobiliers de la justice et la question
de l'accompagnement que nous devons aux
détenus le premier jour de détention et
d'incarcération c'est le premier jour de
réinsertion dans la vie maintenant il y
aura c'est un chantier qui va arriver au
parlement bientôt parce qu'une loi
pénitentiaire est prévue vous avez déjà
une idée de calendrier non non le
gouvernement a annoncé qu'ils auraient
un plan prisons qui serait justement
annoncé dans l'est dans les prochaines
semaines on y sera évidemment très
attentifs parce que je pense justement
que la bonne réponse la réponse adaptée
en matière politique pénale c'est
d'avoir des sanctions juste des
sanctions appliquées et des conditions
de détention qu'ils font en réalité que
le détenu n'est pas dans un processus
d'accélération de dalles de la
délinquance et c'est malheureusement
bien souvent le cas il faut que le
premier jour des tensions
on réfléchit déjà aux conditions de la
sortie du détenu autre sujet hugues
rançon la réforme de la constitution est
en marche
en tout cas pour l'instant l'heure est
toujours aux consultations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un groupe de travail à l'assemblée un
autre au sénat chaque chambre a fait ces
propositions mais on est encore loin
d'un accord
ce qui pourrait éventuellement conduire
le président de la république à se
passer du parlement choisir peut-être
l'option de consulter directement le
peuple face à la menace que le sénat
fait peser sur la révision
constitutionnelle
l'option du référendum se précise
l'article 11 qui permet une consultation
directe des citoyens sans passer par le
vote du parlement pourrait avoir les
faveurs de l'exécutif sur certaines
mesures
c'est ce qu'a confirmé la garde des
sceaux le week-end dernier on pourrait
imaginer un référendum qui porterait à
la fois sur la représenter sur le mode
de scrutin la représentation
proportionnelle sur le nombre de
parlementaires leur diminution à peu
près d'un tiers sur la question du non
cumul des mandats d'antan ce sont
précisément ces points qui coince avec
le sénat des mesures qui pourraient
faire l'objet d'une simple loi ordinaire
ou une loi organique nicole belloubet ex
membre du conseil constitutionnel le
sait bien
ces sujets ne nécessite pas de modifier
la loi fondamentale sur ce point-là pas
d'obligation de modifier la constitution
dans le débat actuel
on mélange tout il y a ce qui relève de
la loi ordinaire
par exemple la modification du mode de
scrutin ce qui relève de la loi
organique
par exemple le nombre de parlementaires
et le la limitation dans le temps du
cumul ne successive de deux mandats
et puis il ya ceux qui relèvent de la
loi constitutionnelle
en clair emmanuel macron pourrait
s'orienter vers une révision de partie
les sujets d'ordre réellement
constitutionnel comme la suppression de
la cour de justice de la république
l'indépendance du conseil supérieur de
la magistrature ou la réforme du conseil
constitutionnel nécessite bien un
congrès mais les points de discorde avec
le sénat donnerait lieu à un référendum
direct sans passer par le vote des élus
une procédure viable d'un point de vue
juridique mais pas sans risques
politiques
il y a de quoi être définitivement fâché
avec la chambre e hôte si on cherche à
la contourner ce qui pourrait faire
échouer l'ensemble de la réforme et
c'était donc un sujet de tam tran huy
grand-sault gérard larcher détient en
partie les clés d'un accord est ce que
vous pensez qu'il peut bloquer cette
réforme
aucun accord est encore possible je ne
crois pas que ce soit dans l'état
d'esprit d'une région du sénat de
bloquer quelques réformes que ce soit
parce que je crois que au fond il n'est
pas aussi conservateur qu'on pourrait le
lire ici ou là en réalité la réforme ce
reportage est très utile parce qu'on
comprend mieux que tout quand on parle
de réformes constitutionnelles il y a en
effet plusieurs niveaux et plusieurs
plusieurs degrés ce que je vais vous
dire ce matin c'est que la réforme
institutionnelle
il s'agit pour nous de transformer la
démocratie de la moderniser c'est aussi
important que la transformation
économique ou que la transformation
sociale n'oublions pas les conditions
dans lesquelles nous sommes arrivés au
pouvoir la défiance vis-à-vis du pouvoir
politique vis-à-vis des institutions
certes nous sommes arrivés au pouvoir
est d'ailleurs notre arrivée prouve
qu'il y avait déjà quelque chose qui ne
fonctionnait pas dans le système
politique mais nous sommes arrivés au
pouvoir avec une abstention très très
forte et avec un vote populiste ou
extrémiste excessivement élevés
aujourd'hui nous voulons réviser le
fonctionnement de la démocratie parce
qu'il faut rétablir cette confiance
entre les citoyens et leurs classes
dirigeantes
c'est essentiel le président de la
république s'y engager à l'occasion de
sa campagne électorale c'est peut-être à
strasbourg il l'a redit au congrès au
mois de juillet dernier c'est un cap
qu'il nous a fixé et nous mènerons cette
réforme dans cette réforme il y a
évidemment des choses qui ont été déjà
annoncées qui était au coeur de notre
programme d pour rendre le parlement
plus efficace avec des parlementaires
moins nombreux avec ce scrutin rénover
des accords avec l'interdiction du cumul
du mandat dans l'espace et dans le temps
il y a évidemment des points de
désaccord avec le sénat mais nous aurons
à aborder ces sujets ensemble vous
l'avez rappelé le président de la fédé
points sur lesquels un compromis peut
être trouvé où il y aura de la fermeté
n'y prête pas à ce stade est évidemment
privilégie pourquoi parce que françois
de rugy a évidemment mis en place des
groupes de travail pour faire des
propositions gérard larcher a rendu les
siennes cette semaine et le président de
la république à un cas aujourd'hui nous
nous avons mandat pour transformer la
démocratie pour obtenir ces trois
cinquièmes un texte institutionnel dont
nous allons fêter le 60ème anniversaire
au mois d'octobre
moi je ne n'ai pas de pronostic à faire
sur le
les résultats d'un congrès je dis juste
que nous avons dans ce domaine comme
dans les autres une obligation de
résultat et que dans ce domaine comme
dans les autres nous mèneront les
réformes pour lesquelles nous avons été
élus il ya plusieurs façons d arriver là
sont de résultats mais nicolas n'oubliez
sommes juste en tant qu en tant que
parlementaire grand soin est ce que ça
ne vous pose pas de problème qu'on passe
au dessus du parlement ce qui me
poserait problème c'est qu'à cause de
conservatisme de gens qui veulent
préserver le système dans lequel ils
sont depuis tant et tant d'années
certains qui ont reçu un mandat des
français ne puissent pas aller au bout
de leur démarche nous nous avons eu un
mandat des français pour transformer la
france aura des lances former le système
politique
si nous ne pouvons pas il mener ses
réformes paris relative parce qu'il y
aurait des conservatismes de part et
d'autre en tout cas qui nous
permettraient pas d'atteindre les 3 6 m
nous précisément je ne sais pas on
verrait qu'il voterait ou pas la baisse
du nombre de parlementaires la fin du
cumul des mandats dans l'espace et dans
le temps
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle nous voulons moderniser
la démocratie nous voulons que la
démocratie soit plus à l'image de la
société française de sa richesse de sa
diversité
aujourd'hui nous voulons ça c'est sûr et
nous le répéterons autant que faire se
peut nous voulons sortir d'un système de
carrière politique ou des professionnels
de la politique vont de mandat en mandat
et puis nous avons d'autres réformes à
faire faire en sorte que la démocratie
soit plus ouvert plus participative
c'est aussi la réforme du c'est ce qui a
été annoncé on s'est il précisément
cette semaine par le président de
république nous mènerons cette réforme à
son terme
on va passer à l'actualité politique de
la semaine avec notre partenaire du
figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour vous interroger grand saut on
accueille gym gère assez bon aujourd'hui
bonjour rien au genre katia mark hughes
rançon valoir les deux mathieu gallet
qui a été révoqué cette semaine à la
tête de radio france après sa
condamnation pour favoritisme ses
avocats ont dénoncé assez fortement les
pressions de l'état est ce que le fait
que la france là la ministre françoise
nyssen et appeler un publiquement la
démission de mathieu gallet est ce que
ça a poussé le crs a à prendre sa
décision est ce qu'il ya eu des
pressions non je ne le crois pas le csa
c'est une autorité administrative
indépendante et le gouvernement n'agit
pas ou ne fut pas sur les décisions des
autorités administratives indépendantes
quelle qu'elle soit et d'ailleurs c'est
le principe des autorités
administratives indépendantes qu'elles
ont un statut qui leur permettent d'être
à l'écart de toute pression politique
donc je ne crois pas une seule seconde
aux politiques dont le gouvernement est
indiqué quelques décisions que ce soit
au csa en revanche la décision
souveraine du csa c'est une décision que
je n'ai pas à commenter le csa nomme il
est normal que le csa puisse défaire une
décision qui a été la sienne aujourd'hui
mathieu gallet est dans une situation il
avait été condamné en première instance
il a fait appel
voilà ce n'est pas à moi de décider ce
n'est pas à moi de le commenter mais il
est naturel que le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel puisse juger de lui-même
de la bonne adéquation d'un profil et
d'un poste dans l'exercie la rendre
responsable avait précisé en effet un
françois si nissan a attendu la
condamnation de mathieu gallet pour
prendre la parole ce n'est pas le cas de
marlène schiappa qui elle s'est exprimée
sur un autre cas très différent celui de
john hutton d'aval qui a avoué avoir tué
sa compagne sa compagne un ministre n'a
pas à commenter une décision de justice
a dit christophe castaner à ce sujet ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec lui c'est ce
sujet est un sujet sensible c'est un
sujet qui fait l'actualité et
et mme alain chabat fait beaucoup
avancer le combat pour le droit des
femmes pour la libération de la parole
et je crois qu'elle a parlé avec son
coeur et que souvent à trop vite
elle arrive à faire bouger les lignes
dans cette société sur cinq sujets et
donc quand marlène schiappa parle je
crois qu'elle arrive à faire bouger les
lignes dans le pays si important que
vous êtes en désaccord avec christophe
castaner sûr pour autant mais ne laissez
pas de trouver des désaccords 9 castaner
marlène schiappa et les parlementaires
marlène schiappa est très utile par
rapport à cette cause là et elle a parlé
avec son coeur sur un sujet sensible
dont on voit jouer un rôle clé dans la
formation je regarde les informations
car que la raison je vois qu'elle fait
l'actualité depuis trois jours parce
qu'elle elle suscite beaucoup d'émotion
dans le pays
christophe castaner rappelle que un
ministre n'a pas à commander une
procédure judiciaire et christophe
castaner a raison on n'a pas à rentrer
mais pas que les miss les politiques
n'ont plus la commenter des plaidoiries
ou des positions les avocats des uns ou
des autres dans quelque affaire que ce
soit prennent les positions qu'ils
veulent pour défendre leurs clients
entreprises et de l'autre un autre cas
encore très différents c'est celui de
gérald darmanin qui est lui aussi mis en
cause il ya une standing-ovation à
l'assemblée nationale cette semaine est
ce que les députés en mars ne sont pas
allés trop loin justement là encore la
sphère n'a pas été jugé alors je ne
crois pas si vous avez bien suivi les
débats que la standing-ovation avait un
lien avec l'affairé en question s'est
allié à s'arrêter plus encore une
question il a été posé et lorsqu'un
ministre article à une réponse
percutante détaillé et qui nous paraît
être de nature à relever les défis que
se posent au pays
nous la position gérald darmanin à toute
la cocagne un mec la tourmente
toute la confiance de la majorité pour
mener les chantiers importants qui l'a
amené là ma confiance personnelle
évidemment et ensuite justice fait son
travail dans ce pays si c'est pas moi de
savoir si gérald darmanin a eu un
comportement respectueux pénalement
répréhensible ou non dernière chose
avance et ce n'est pas interdit aux
médias de cette dernière question au
sujet de richard ferrand
on a raconté que vous étiez élevé lors
d'une réunion de groupe qui a annoncé la
réorganisation des postes au sein du
groupe en marche organisée justement par
richard ferrand est ce que c'est un bon
président groupe richard ferrand oui
richard ferrand est un bon président du
groupe j'ai pour lui beaucoup d estime
et beaucoup de reconnaissance pour le
travail qui fait qu'ils aient un travail
difficile d'animer une équipe de 300
députés qui viennent d'horizons
différents aujourd'hui il faut animer
ces différentes sensibilités
il faut animer ces courants de pensée au
sein d'une famille politique qui vient
de se constituer et nous devons faire
émerger des talents mais nous pouvons
aussi dans une famille politique nous
dire les choses et s était évidemment le
sens et se coupa en réunion de groupe
dont vous avez eu vent et s'ils
n'avaient pas vocation à sortir dans la
presse
eh bien ce sera le mot de la fin merci
bonjour d'avoir été notre invité merci à
tous de nous avoir suivis et très bonne
semaine sur les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]